sındıracak kalıpları en büyük
destekçisinin Ben Konfor alanında
olduğunu düşünüyorum o oranından
çıkmakta bir felç meselesi Bence kendi
Konfor alanlarından defalarca çıktığını
düşünüyorum Hatta hayatımı zor
laştırdı ve
bunda daha daha zorlaştırdığını
düşünüyorum ve
doğru seviyorum diye düşünüyorum Aslında
yapabilmemi sağlayan değerli olduğunu
düşündüğünün farkındalıklar var
farkındalıklardan bahsed
ebiliriz
üniversite
hazırlanırken özellikle
Ne istediğimi bilmiyordum abim
Ankara
hamsi ziyarete gitmiştim bana Kampüsü
gezdirmişti ODTÜ'de okuyordu
tahsilya'dan sonra zaten hayatına ilk
defa bir üniversite kampüsüne
girdikten sonra da zaten tek hedeflerini
belirlemiştim çok da düşünme
karıştırmadan tüm opsiyonları kapağında
silmiştim
genelde küçük muhafazakarlık kapalı
toplumlarda yaşadığım için çok fazla
kendini keşfetme imkanım olmamıştı
üniversitede artık kendimi keşfetmeye
başlamıştım çok da başarılı bir öğrenci
olamadım açıkçası Çünkü çok daha
anlamıyorum
aynı zamanda çalışmaya da başladım
üniversitede falan Benim için özel günüm
değildi
duygusal hayata geçiş yaptım yaklaşık 10
sene kadar kutsal hayatta çalıştım Eee o
Asena çok fazla Kendimi geliştirdim ve
çok öğrendiğim düşünüyordum bu 10
senenin verdiği Tabii Ee Konfor alanı
var hem strate hem de gelir olarak
bu Konfor alanında tatmin Konfor alalım
ve
burada Belli bir yerden sonra ama bence
asıl konford
kalabilecek kişisel gelişimi
ve daha sonra gelen bir teknik üzerine
Ben giriş
iminde bambaşka bir ailem gerçekten
cesaret işi hatta biraz deli
işleyebilirim
Ben gördüğüm kadarıyla insanlardan
şöyle bir şey vardı aslında girişimleri
destekleyen onların adı İngilizcesi ben
mağazası bulundu bencher'ın sözlük
anlamlarından birisi de yani cesaret
gösterip başarılı olabilen veya başarılı
olma pot
ansiyeli
girişimcilik kurumsal hayatta 10 senedir
yaklaşık 10-3 tane şirkette çalışsın
toplamda Ama son 8 senede kendi
başarısız deneyimlerinde dahil olmak
üzere onun
la hepsi çok farklı hikayelerde
bulunuyor
aynı zamanda
girişimcilik destekleme programları var
girişimcileri mentollü veriyorum Şu ana
kadar 300'ün üstünde
girişimci ile sohbet etme imkanım oldu
her konuştuğum girişimizi farklı bir
ilham kaynağı sağlıyor farkında bakış
açısı farklı başarı hikayesi olarak
düşünebilirim
hepsi beni güncel tutmaya yardımcı
oluyor
kendi özetle
[Müzik]
üçüncü farkındalığım ise geçmişe
takılmadan geleceğe odaklanmak geçmişte
yaşadığımız tecrübelere bir hayat
tecrübelerden bir hayatımız var iyisiyle
köt
üsüyle geçmişten öğrenelim dersler
çıkaralım tabi ama
almak keşkeler
le geri
de bırakabilir
dikkatleri taşımak
şu an anı yaşıyoruz keyfini çıkarmamız
gerektiğini
Çünkü Ağın tüm hayatımızda çok küçük bir
kısmı teşkil ediyor elimizde bir tek
gelecek var fırsatta aslında gelecek
devlet yok ayrıca gelecekle ilgili
hayaller bizim hem motive ediyor hem de
geçmişim derslerimizden
[Müzik]
konuşmamızı yardımcı oluyor 4
farkındalığı bilgi ve tecrübenin önemi
biliyorsunuz Herkes her konuda fikri var
düşünce ve ifade
Özgür gayet olması gereken bir şey
insanların fikirlerini de dinlemek
gerekiyor ama
biraz böyle sorgulayıcı olmak
gerektiğini düşünüyorum ben kendim
aklıma takılan bir fikir olursa yani
okumayı tercih ediyorum çünkü aklımda
yanlış bilgilerin yönetmesini
istemiyorum
aklımda yatmayan bir fikir varsa ve
evimi de çekerse araştırmayı ben tercih
ediyorum araştırıp öğrenmeyi kendi
araçları öğrenmeyi seviyorum bunun
içinde
emekliye etmemize yardımcı olacak hayatı
becerileri öğrenmek alışkanlık haline
getirmek hem garantisi güçlü kılar hem
de
Hayat kalitemizi arttırır
özellikle farklı cisimlerde yeni
bilgiler ve yetenekler elde etmek bakış
açımızı derinleştirir fark yaratmanıza
yardımcı olabilir biliyorum Çok
bilgisayar Ama zaten
sizde Çünkü kendimize yapabileceğimiz
en iyi 5 parfüm dalımın Risk almak
denemek hata yapmak
başarısızlığın ve Risk almaktan
korkmadan denemeler yapmak kendinizi
keşfetmemiz için önemli büyük adımlar
atlanma yani büyük risklerince yeterince
tecrübe kazanma tecrübeli olmamız
gerekiyor
Bazı insanlar sizleri nasıl
yapamayacağınızı anlat
mayı bizim vermeyebilirsiniz
yapabileceğiniz düşünürseniz düşünerek
Cesur olup denemeliyiz geçmişte yapılan
vaatlerinden birçok şeyi bilen insanlar
la yaşamak
hedeflerimizi belirlemek ve
önceliklendirmek değerli göstericiler
olabilir
belirlediğimiz hedefleri takip etmek
ilerlemeyi gözetlemek ve finans Hatip
almak gerekir sürekli hedeflerimizin
başarılı tamamlamak başarılı aşırı
özgüveni ve tatminsizliğe yol açabilir
Bu yüzden hedeflerimizi yüksek tutmak
motivasyonu kaybetmek önemlidir geçmişte
başarısızlıklarla sonuçlanan
düşündüğümüz bir çok tecrübe olabilir
Bunları kendimizi
görmeliyiz Sonuç olarak yani işte
bir marka olarak değerlendirebiliriz
Aslında ve aynı dönemde
yeteneklerimizle uzmanlıklarımızı
geliştirmek markamızı parlatmamıza
yardımcı olur fırsatlar genellikle
ayağımıza geldiğinde bazen çekip
çıkarmak gerekiyor o yüzden
algılarımızın açık
olması olmak yorumda olmak ve öne çıkmak
gerekiyor Yani bizim tanıdıktan sonra
geliştirdikten sonra hedeflerimizle
belirtileri daha sonra risk alıp
ilerlemek için
ilerlememek için bir sebep kalmıyor
Denemeden bilemeyiz teşekkürler